it's time for roses and the day with me
I know I don't really have a voice how
can I still manage to be this loud I
don't know it really annoyed my parents
but but uh hi you guys wow I didn't even
fake that we are pulling back the veil
on roses and rose a today breaking the
fourth wall it wasn't ever really there
but really we're just being super real
I'm sick and this is it rose a today for
the first time we're having a
non-alcoholic drink its water because I
got up couldn't hydrate mmm so you guys
you are gonna see me in a different
outfit later in this video because
earlier today I filmed my reaction to
episode 7 of season 8 and let me know
season of The Bachelorette because of
course have you been following along
we've been recapping to figure out who
the re is but what I literally just
walked away from watching was the
countdown to re special on ABC so ABC is
getting excited about re 2 and as they
often do they did a little special to
get us all pumped up and we are gonna go
through it because they have as meet
some of our ease women it's gonna be
absolute mayhem and carnage first they
look back at Emily's season but we don't
need to do that because we have been
doing it so fast-forward that's what I
did and then Ari says that after his
breakup with Emily when Emily broke up
with me that heartbreak was hard
so after the breakup I was racing
constantly race away from the trouble in
the past in the drama by a sorrow SIA
and now we are talking like ari and
seeing his family and like everyone is
saying that Ari is just he's so ready
he's so ready it's been 15 years since
Emily he was ready then and he had date
as well with kids then so he's really
getting ready okay now we're gonna meet
some of the women first we have a woman
whose name I forgot she's a professional
photographer Oh a real job but she's 23
now I'm not trying to be an ageist but
sometimes it's hard to be in the same
life place as a 36 year old when you're
23 hopefully he likes me to say also you
know the premise of the show is still
resting on the laurels of that like
these are supposed to be people have
been struggling to find love you're 28
skin 3 keep struggling you have more
gears and struggling you bro you just
you just graduated college get here fine
then we have an Arkansas girl and she
has nowhere to sit but inside this
tractor wheel okay and then we have
Becca drink every time Mike off cuz I
have two and Becca spells her name weird
and she's a nanny but also a rock
climber and this is great because it
shows us the people of depth that they
different they didn't be a nanny and a
rock climber but that's great I mean she
looks very young so it either has to be
that she's like so young like 19 or
something or that she looks very young
but is in fact much older
so then we have I think nice sure and ie
should I forget and she's a nurse and
she loves gunshot wounds gunshot wounds
love it out the more blood the better
for me
she said that okay so Kendell is 26 and
she's also from LA and she collects dead
animals and dead relationships yes she
didn't say that relationships but she's
into taxidermy and she says that she
hasn't had a relationship that has
lasted over a year look I don't judge I
don't judge you know because someone
could come on this show for a totally
different reason and actually really
fall for the person so I don't judge
Kendall do you think then we have
Marique she's 27 and she owns a
restaurant in Utah but what we're gonna
do is watch her beat up this guy okay
and then we have Caroline she's from
Florida and she is very confident and I
like her she says she's good at her job
and I like her saying that good for you
Caroline and she's real estate agent
which has also been Army's job since we
last met him and that's all that the
women that we're gonna meet but you guys
can get more details on the gals over at
et online.com sorry for the voice crap
I'm barely I'm barely able to speak
right now if I massage it this whole
time kind of okay and so now we're gonna
get some updates update on Rachel and
Brian they're living in Dallas they're
great we already knew this because I
interviewed them very recently that's
easy online comm same was
[Music]
and then update on Sean and Catherine
they're also in Dallas they're so cute
should they have their baby Samuel and
she's fighting with another baby and
everything's great and we already knew
that because I recently interviewed them
and somebody's yelling calm I haven't a
gnarly and you know what they're
catching up with them and they're in
Nashville and they're she's pregnant
it's a girl in there great oh yeah it's
a girl
no one does that right it's like she's
trying to reveal something on this
special she's so adorable she's like
it's it's a girl they didn't know that
Evan they didn't know that it's a girl
no we didn't know that Carly you
announced that news in August then we
get into the preview which is why the
preview is Ari walking through what
looks to be the Sahara Desert
in a full suit and even though he sweat
so much in Emily Maynard season he's not
sweating in this suit in this desert
which makes it like is it real like is
it green screen I don't know why is he
in a suit in the desert I don't even
press releases those are gonna go to
Paris and they're gonna go to Peru and
they're gonna go to Tuscany so you know
wait for that sorry I should have said
spoiler alert but that's where they're
going you knew they were gonna go to
cool places when does he go into a
desert so you know then we get teases of
drama and tears in this like age thing
and a woman who's a mom and she doesn't
like the people seem to be upset that
she's a mom and and just drama I love my
live drama it's great and some very
dangerous jetski behavior and clearly
Arya's gonna be doing a lot of kissing
yeah by the way you guys I was wondering
like is his kissing gonna be just as
good with women other than Emily I said
this a few episodes or so ago and a
source tells me
yes and I'll see you in about 10 seconds
to recap Emily Maynard's season 8
episodes 7 & 8
see you guys don't turn this video off
let's all go to the lobby with me hi you
guys oh my gosh we have already covered
so much if you've been watching we've
covered Ari's countdown to Ari we've
covered weight and now let me do it
again but experiencing the effects of a
lot of homeopathic natural medicines and
herbs and things and I'm pretty out of
it so there we go
you know when you want something in life
you've got to go get it okay so we are
here to talk about Emily maynard's
episodes 7 & 8 of season 8 of The
Bachelor rats first let's discuss
episode 7
bum-bum-bum I know something about Arie
that he's not telling me Ari and the
producer whoa I did not see this coming
and apparently Emily didn't either
it's weird to grab a dog that's
represents loyalty when I know in the
back of my head she has a secret
it's hiding from me yeah you should do
it twice yes so it turns out and I'm
guessing this is like a big scandal at
the time Ari
dated a producer on the show and Chris
Harrison says her name about 46 times
pasty Lambert but I can't remember at
this point maybe like Cassie Lambert or
Cassandra Lambert Cassie short for
Cassandra anyway what else is he hiding
they dated forever ago but Ari and this
producer did not mention it to Emily and
then the producer does tell Emily and
Emily feels betrayed and they discuss it
and they have a discussion off-camera
off-camera really really really with all
the cameras you have you talk about off
camera is a reality show and Chris
Harrison's like unfortunately it
happened off camera which made me think
that the producers were like how was
this not filmed and they were annoyed
but ultimately Emily was okay with
everything and I don't know I you know
what I wanted I wanted the specifics
like because re and this producer kept
saying they didn't think it was worth
mentioning so does that mean they wanted
one date like ten years ago or what are
we talking here
well it's not worth mentioning I'd say
if you're not in the exclusive
relationship with someone it's not worth
mentioning but if you date it maybe you
know what I don't know I don't know
relationships mmm
stay hydrated okay please excuse my
voice I'm like erielle when she gives up
her voice to find love
[Music]
okay I've really gotta let go of the
childhood dream of becoming a mermaid
it's not happen for me so Arie and Emily
have their date in Prague like when they
figure out all this stuff with the
bachelor producer thing and it's fine
it's all good I think that's why I like
from the curvaceous so much because I
think I realized that I love you I
always thought after our first date that
I was falling in love with you like that
point I realized it then Shawn wants
more time with Emily so he runs around
Prague yelling Emily Emily Emily and
like literally he's running around
Prague trying to find her they think we
buy this and then Emily just walking
down a dark Street and Prague all by
herself and Shawn finds her yeah yeah
and even says like why are you walking
down the street in Prague right on your
own great question
she shouldn't be it's for television
shot okay I think I'm being choked yeah
no one's been oh yeah so Shawn is like
I'm gonna spend time with Emily and be
really proactive about that figure out
how to do it Chris keeps being whining
about how he's not getting time with
Emily I bet when he went back and
watched Shawn do this he was kicking
himself but he didn't run around Prague
screaming Emily Emily Plus you know get
your steps in for the day mmm this is so
much water I'm just gonna you know I
gotta fight this ever seen during some
water for a few minutes why is water
harder to chug than wine basically I'm
drowning myself oh okay
[Music]
I don't like those Rose ceremonies I
thought last time I was gonna go home
and I keep really like I really don't
want to go home
Emily's trying to figure out if she goes
to hometowns with Doug cuz the hometowns
are coming up what is she gonna learn
about Doug and what side of Doug is she
didn't see and he says nothing nothing
but you know the thing is is you'd like
gotta learn anything about me I think
that was the clincher for Emily that it
was time to cut the cord on Doug like
they catching no no I wouldn't I just
wasn't anyway we're good
so Doug and Emily are I mean Emily's
clearly dumping him he still hasn't
kissed her at this point I forgot this
Sunkist I mean wow so then Emily's
clearly dumping Doug and in sad
last-ditch effort I guess to stop her
mid dumped Doug the dumpy dumps a kiss
on her face really quick thank you for
that yep
you know I ain't and shockingly that
didn't work it was so awkward and then
he's like I feel like an idiot for
kissing you well yeah yeah who kisses
someone for the first time while they're
breaking up with them like that's what
happened
yikes chris is at a boiling point mm oh
my god and then Jeff and Emily have a
date together a one-on-one and they have
these puppets and they start recreating
their relationship moments with the
puppets and I'm like is this actually
not a date but instead therapy I really
like your nail polish it turns out it is
cuz Jeff's like oh I can say my feelings
through these puppets since we have
these puppets it and somehow makes it
easier it was really it was more of an
exercise than a romantical moment and
then Jeff gives me more confusing cuz
he's like his puppet is saying he's in
love with her I am 100
1 million percent in love with you but
then he's like I liked you in real life
so I guess Jeff didn't say more with the
puppet than he can say on his own one of
many reasons why I still am questioning
the Jeff thing oh what a moment they're
going down the floor of a library it's
like beauty in the beasts style little
town is a quad I gotta stop ah you're
not a princess you're not a princess
you're not a princess what a harsh
reality and so Jeff is kind of like
seeing everything it seems that Emily
would want to hear like he is totally on
board if not living together before
marriage and he can't wait to be a dad
remember Jeff's pretty much the youngest
guy left at this point I think him and
Chris are and Jeff then says he wants to
be a dad because he can't wait to be a
fun dad the fun that I pictured like you
and I fighting Emily is into this why
dude don't ever say you want to be a fun
dad I want someone who's like yeah I'll
be up with you at 3:00 in the morning
changing a diaper and we'll be talking
ourselves down from a Ledge as this kid
is screaming for the fifth hour on end
neither of us have slept and neither
receivin know who we are anymore and we
can't remember who we were before we had
kids and we're just holding on clinging
on to our relationship as we continue on
this new journey of parenting which one
thing will probably feel really fruitful
but for right now those incredibly
stressful and overwhelming we're
thinking why did we do this I want that
guy by my side not the fun dad Emily's
like yeah it'll be so cute when you
won't when you won't discipline that
what tell go and send them to their
rooms and let me have a glass of wine
okay that's the guy I'm looking for
fun dad no thanks Jeff skateboards your
way on out of here anyway so Jeff tells
her he wants to quote nice alright what
a sentiment and at the end of the day
Chris makes a last-ditch effort to speak
to Emily even though there's not a rose
ceremony and John is sent home and none
of it's shocking and frankly Chris
father should have been sent home too
because I don't know it's really it's
feeling like Sean and Arie and Jef right
and it's not that way the whole time
even knowing what happened i think
watching the season I would have felt
like it was always Sean and Arie and Jef
so episode 8 will be hometowns I will be
back to talk about that in a few minutes
[Music]
it's time for roses and Rosie you guys
it's me again in the same outfit you saw
me in earlier oh my god yes okay again
we're breaking down the fourth wall of
TV here so I taped countdown to Ari and
I taped my review of episode 8 seasoning
Emily me never season a bachelor at the
same time so that's why I'm wearing this
outfit and here we are let's get to it
thank you for being here so far so
episode 8 is hometowns Emily goes to
Chris's hometown I am in love with you
mmm
Jess hometown are his hometown and shots
Emily she's describing each guy in the
beginning kind of summing them up and
she says that Arie has a bad-boy edge re
definitely had that bad point edge he
does he seemed like super pretty
wholesome this like whole freakin time
to me except for when he told her that
he once got a tattoo of his exes name
with any guy who covered up so that was
surprising to me I think Emily just
wants a guy with a bad boy and she
really likes kissing arias maybe she's
just saying that Arie has a bad-boy edge
because that's what she wants like she
wants a good guy but she wants a little
bad boy don't we all I don't know anyway
we're demanding
so she says guys like Aria are hard to
find then that she'd be totally adored
with him true true true and
taking so much to see so much to come
then we meet Chris's family there in
Chicago they're really nice
Midwesterners we all know chris is gonna
go home there's not much else to say
there then Jeb's hometown his parents
aren't there which was kind of weird in
Utah he said they're doing charity work
and his siblings don't seem to be like
totally confirming that Jeff is ready
for all this marriage and kids stuff
I've never seen you want those things
yet like Emily asked about it and it's
like crickets and yeah anyway I wrote
down a bunch of stuff and I want to read
it to you telling her he's really in
love with her he writes her this letter
this letter this is a letter that Emily
says contains the nicest things anyone's
ever said to her I think the letter was
key I really do
even though all right was the first one
to say he was love with her which I
forgot to talk about stocky write of his
since seven so let me try to redeem
myself now Arie was the first one to say
he loved her no why does Jeff have such
a hard time communicating like just
saying things yeah there has communicate
through puppets or letters like just say
it anyway I love that he is so humble
and but so like confident Emily I was
Jeff's a bad boy but she says quote it
feels perfect inside my heart and that's
what really matters to me
I don't know what that means Emily it
feels perfect inside your heart does it
feel perfect out in the real world it
wasn't okay then we have our hometown in
Arizona and Ari's parents are there and
I'm like all right kind of warned Emily
about his mom he's like she's gonna be a
tough cookie a tough nut to crack so
thank you those cats on the mouth and
his barons start speaking Dutch to each
other and Emily's like this is so
awkward I can't understand that we don't
get a translation like we don't get an
onscreen translation which is crazy to
me I mean I mean pay for the translator
but Ari says the basically like his mom
was just asking how things went but it
seems kind of shady you know and his mom
seemed kind of shady which I like made
me really excited to see her dad on The
Bachelor
like I love a mom with some character
you know it doesn't have to be all sugar
nice European spice and I love all the
bachelor moms like there were so many
great ones like JoJo's mama was kind of
drunk with the champagne I mean that was
great
so then our he drops a bomb that this
time I won't gloss over bum bum bum bum
bum bum he says he is definitely
definitely going to marry Emily I'm
ready to ask her hand in marriage I'm
ready to propose that's my body reacting
to that statement because it didn't
happen you guys oh so painful it's so
painful they even included that
soundbite in the calendar right next it
was so painful he was so sure I'm
getting it now then Emily needs Sean's
family like they're perfect and she says
like bye honey to him and then Sean runs
after Emily again when she leaves like
MLA Emily Emily again easy wanted to
kiss her again and again like I just I
don't know what goes wrong with Emily
and Sean because they seemed so perfect
like blondes and like southern charm and
like just faith and family and just
everything I can't figure it out anyway
Chris goes home we're not shocked what
an episode this has been you guys thank
you for sticking with me through it all
and we are going to double up in the
month of December we're gonna be doing
double episodes just like we did tonight
although it's 9 was 3 I'm sick I can't
count okay what am I kidding I can't
count when I'm not sick anyways math so
we are going to be doing it two episodes
each week for the next few weeks to
finish up Ari's season of The Bachelor
with Emily Maynard ahead of Ari's season
of The Bachelor premiere on January 2nd
on ABC and we know the girls now and
it's very exciting so head to ET
online.com for more info also let me
tease for you
I have now interviewed Ari and it's
great and it's coming to Entertainment
Tonight sue and so look out for that
that's all you guys I wish I could tell
you more but I can't so more to come and
you know I'm gonna go to sleep I love
you so much thank you for being here
with me bye
[Music]